Hồi con thương ngày 1,5% công bố thông viên chính thức bệ việc Mỹ được chính mất tế đối ứng áp dụng bởi với Việt Nam,
giảm tư bố mê sáo phần chăm số còn 2 mề phần chăm.
Đây là kết quả từ nhiều phíanh đam phán thương mại đối ứng được tổ chức từ quay tháng tư năm 2019,
hãy bình ở cả cấp ký thuật và cấp bộ chương.
Đoàn đam phán chính phủ Việt Nam sò bộ chương bố con thương giãn đầu đã làm việc chức tiếp và chức tuyên
với bộ chương thương mại Mỹ và chương cơ quan đại dị thương mại Mỹ.
2 bên thảo lận về thuê quan, quý tắc xuất sử, nông nghiệp, xời hữu chi tự, thương mại số,
dịch vụ, đồ tư và phát triển Việt vấn.
Theo sắc lệnh được nhờ chẳng banh hành giảng 3 ngày 1 mộ tháng tắm,
dự Việt Nam, Việt Nam làm trong dành xác xóo mê chi quốc gia được đự chình giảm phê đối ứng.
Bộ con thương khẳng định 2 bên sẽ tức tục thảo lận nhằm tư tối thỏa phận quan dịch,
chiến viên tắc bình đam, cùng có lợi.
5 ngày khu trông ai mi tư, kiến ngày thứ mại 2 chiều đặt 1 chăm bố mấy chiến
về bài tí USD, trong năm thẳng đầu 5 ngày khu trông ai mi lâm,
đặt bởi vì bởi phẩy bốn tí USD, tăng 3 mề sảo vệ 5 phần chăm so với cụ kì.